they have their shills and their useful
idiots
already which brings me to the next
story yahoo news
100 plus politico staffers send letter
to ceo
railing against publishing ben shapiro
and this is an example so
we're just talking about is that if you
if you're starting to become too
influential too powerful
they'll come after you try and take you
down if what you're saying goes against
the established narrative they will try
and stop you
ben shapiro is fairly mainstream
conservative so he's not very
threatening but there are many people
and they've been banned parlor for
instance
parlor's a threat to the nerve banned
now ben shapiro is still
not perfectly aligned so he's just
outside where
they want the narrative to be here's
what happens
yahoo says more than 100 politico
staffers
signed onto a letter to publisher robert
albritton expressing disgust with
allowing right wing firebrand ben
shapiro
to guest author one day's edition of the
playbook
and with the outlet subsequent handling
of the fallout earlier this month the
beltway news outlet
handed over the keys to its signature
news product to shapiro
a talk radio host and pundit who has
long been one of the most controversial
voices in right-wing media
that's actually 100 not true in
right-wing media
ben shapiro is not controversial at all
he's actually fairly
i mean yeah well i was going to say with
all due respect tepid
like you're not turning on ben shapiro
and hearing some ranting lunatic calling
for insurrection you're hearing a guy
giving his opinion and it's like clear
yeah he's a lawyer and it's very much
like oh that was a good point ben and
it's very normal
but the worst thing about this is that
it's journalists doing it to me
i can say this as a journalist they're
not journalists okay they're people who
call themselves journalists
and if you're a journalist and you don't
believe in open debate and free speech
and you think other people's ideas make
you
unsafe right you are not a journalist
learn to code
do something else because you do not
belong in this look i'm going to get
banned for that yeah
yeah but it's seriously it's sick i mean
these people have come to see
ostensibly neutral outlets like politico
is not supposed to be a left-wing thing
it's not supposed to be jacobin right
as their zones where even just a
momentary one-day
intervention of a conservative voice
violates their safe space makes them
feel betrayed by the institution they
work for
that is diagnostic of a sick mentality
well here's what they say according to
multiple politico insiders familiar with
the situation
the letter to albritton all britain
criticized the decision to publish
shapiro claiming it had demoralized a
substantial portion of the newsroom
but also railed against the response to
criticism offered by editor-in-chief
matt kaminsky
it's an internal matter and will be
handled as such a political spokesperson
told the daily beast
during a combative meeting on january
14th the day of shapiro's publication
the top editor defended the editorial
decision to irate staffers by claiming
mischief making has always been a part
of politico's secret sauce
we were an upstart some of that
sensibility is always going to be a part
of this publication
the staff letter sent last week to all
britain maintained that kaminsky had not
appropriately apologized
for his responses additionally
referencing an email he said to staff on
january 15
which was obtained and reviewed by the
daily daily beast
the top editor expressed regret for his
initial response about making mischief
but reiterated that publishing shapiro
was part of his hopes to experiment
and mix things up and that's why they
don't like it
because i'm sure there were a lot of new
conservatives who came to politico
and liked what they were seeing and
there are probably some moderates who
heard an opinion that heard before
but let me tell you why this is all bs
it's very very simple
remember when there was a collective
scream
that we all could physically hear when
tom cotton wrote an op-ed saying send in
the troops
it was like one day i just heard and i
was like what's happening up in my
window i could hear it everywhere i was
aw
all of these left is screaming in news
media by the way
about how awful it was that they dared
publish this in the new york times
send in the troops tom cotton said to
end the riots in portland
and uh then they sent in 25 000 troops
to washington dc
to prevent an insurrection oh but that's
different
that's okay now they're all happy now
they're all like
well it's good that we have our security
here they're keeping us safe apparently
nancy pelosi requested crew-manned
machine guns
in a civilian yes this is uh um was it
ken cuccinelli
i think he said this yeah it's it's it's
a remarkable
in a civilian town in a city i know this
federal jurisdiction
reported i should say kentucky chile
said she requested this of them
could you imagine what would happen if a
bunch of unarmed trump supporters well
some of them were armed but a large
group of angry trump supporters are like
waving trump flags and like shaking a
fence
and then nancy pelosi was like use the
crew man machine guns
there's civilian buildings nearby you
can't do that in the city are you nuts
so apparently they were like no no we
don't do that here like
that's not how things go where's the
outcry from the left now
so they're complaining about ben shapiro
no it's not fair you're publishing him
but we know their their complaints are
bs it's there's no conservative they
would accept i mean right unless a
conservative that's just to confirm all
their beliefs
and go totally never trump and become
jennifer rubin you know max boot
but here's the thing that bothers me too
it's not even that they were objecting
to the content of what he wrote
they were objecting to just him as a
person being allowed to speak
in that platform because of like tweets
from 2007 or something that
upset them it would be actually at least
something we could fight against and
debate if they were saying that column
was bad
and shouldn't have been published no one
cares about none of these people
freaking out about it could tell you
what he wrote
most of them didn't even read it i would
bet i don't even know a thousand dollars
it was about impeachment
it was about saying well here's why
senate republicans aren't going to
support impeachment
i talked to them they tell me this it
was not even very opinionated he said
democrats
right the funny thing is he does have a
style that can be uh like you said kind
of combative but he's very mainstream
he's not he's not the razor fire brand
that you'd think these people couldn't
handle if they can't handle him
there's no one they can handle but the
problem is that they frame their
opposition to him as a matter of safety
and that will never stop bothering me
ben shapiro's ideas make other people
unsafe
well then there's something wrong with
you you're not an adult you need to
return to fifth grade
and develop the emotional stability of a
grown human being but you know what man
i read the story
a long time ago about this family that
was on a beach and then it was like
it was a dad his wife and they're like
two kids and then all of a sudden they
saw a large black wolf
walking down the beach and they panicked
and they swam
out to this rock that was like you know
20 30 feet
out and they huddled together on it
shaking
dripping wet for warmth as the wolf
paced back and forth
and it was like this harrowing
experience the man it recounted
and i was thinking about that and i'm
like i wonder what would have happened
200 years ago
would he have pulled out his like
flintlock pistol and his sword and said
protect the kids
bang and then like drew his sword to
protect them from the wild beasts
or would they have hidden and shivered
and imagined back in the day when we
were faced with these very serious
challenges and men literally walked
around
armed all the time something like that
probably wouldn't have happened
it was a couple hundred years ago well
let's say even a hundred years ago that
probably would have had a gun on his
belt you know when he was and he
probably would have just shot the thing
or something like that
now today's day and age you still have
circumstances where a dude who lives out
in the middle of nowhere with his family
is going to be armed
but what the point i'm bringing up is
like i read that story and i thought to
myself like would that would like
are we gradually just getting weaker and
more scared of everything
i think the answer is yes and this story
is a perfect example ben shapiro's
opinions now make you unsafe
you have these colleges where they say
things like that you know
their speech is violence like they
literally now think the
but think about it you have these kids
who grow up where they get participation
trophies
where no one's allowed to pick on them
or insult them in any way and then they
actually
they probably feel real physical pain
they can't deal with when someone calls
them like a stupid doo-doo head they're
like
it hurts i've never experienced this
pain before it feeds into itself right
because if you start not being exposed
to different ideas or different opinions
you don't ever develop the thick skin
and then it just becomes more and more
out of control to the point where they
because the thing is when they can frame
other people's speech as violence
or endangering their safety that is the
necessary precursor they have to get to
logically argue they should be allowed
to shut down that speech preemptively
because if it's just really offensive
most people won't agree they should be
able to shut it down well to bypass the
first amendment
right exactly even do that here they
said that this demoralized the newsroom
and most of their complaint was the with
this guy who said that
part of what politico did was cause
mischief so they're not even saying that
it was making them feel like that's so
dangerous how pathetic was it lies
how pathetic was it even claim having
been shapiro right in an op-ed was
mischief
it's not really not he's a mainstream
high-profile prominent conservative one
of the biggest podcasts in the world
it was boilerplate too the actual
article the article was not
controversial he's written some
controversial books
right it wasn't like he was writing
about trans issues it wasn't like he was
writing about abortion
he was explaining senate republicans
rationale on impeachment
it's like you said they're objecting to
him yes he could have walked and said
hey i'm banned shapiro and they would
went like
they let him in the building and they
would all scream and like one guy jumps
out the window
and then he's like okay but i will say
it only helps him
right it's like it is an example of like
they only confirm everything he says
about the liberal media when they do
stuff like this and they don't seem to
realize that they're just
making they're proving his point and
they're only propping him up that's
another thing we have to understand here
like this is
this is backfiring and lucky luckily it
is because sometimes it doesn't and they
get their way
but we can't give uh give our way to
these people that are
i think clinically insane i mean if
you're at a point in life where hearing
words
makes you feel pain what's what's wrong
with you and
again i keep reminding people one of the
most important powers you have as a
human being
is the power of your reaction i got i i
gotta i gotta add to this you know just
to say i'm i'm not a long
time gun person you know i i always tell
the story in january of last year i was
like i don't want any guns at my house
now we got a bunch luke's talking about
buying a 50 cal and all
like yeah okay so we like guns and uh i
remember seeing that story from
the journalist who claimed he got ptsd
from firing an ar-15
do you have any sorry yeah who did you
write with i think it was abc
i'm not sure he fired an ar and i i bet
what what
that was probably like five five six
yeah and he claimed that he got ptsd
from shooting it he could feel the shock
wave
and it hurt his arm and all that and i'm
like here's what's funny because
it's something i didn't understand until
actually experienced it
game load for a shotgun when you're
hunting turkeys
has more recoil is a bigger explosion
than an ar-15
so when like when we went to the range
and we had bird shot i'm like man you
can feel that bird shot
and then when you're flying the ar it's
like actually not that
much at all relative so if this guy is
getting ptsd
from an ar-15 complaining it's like it's
a weapon of war and he could he was
traumatized
from it i'm like well heaven forbid you
have to hunt a turkey it was like wow
it was the daily news the title was what
is it like to fire an ar-15
it's horrifying menacing and very very
loud
at 26. gersh cuntsman fittingly
uh 2016
and the first uh headline here it says
it felt to me like a bazooka
and sounded like a cannon he said he
said the explosions loud like a bomb
gave me a temporary form of ptsd for at
least an hour after firing the gun just
a few times i was anxious and irritable
that's kind of offensive to ptsd victims
yes very much so
my favorite image that people have
posted on this as a meme is a little
girl with a pink shotgun
shooting she's great i think she has her
own like
instagram page where she does when she
does competitive shooting
i was thinking oh wait wait wait look
there was an update on the story says
many people have objected to my use of
the term ptsd in the above story
the use of this term was in no way meant
to conflate my very temporary anxiety
with the very real condition experienced
by many of our brave men and women in
uniform
i regret the inarticulate use of the
term to describe my in the moment
impression of the gun's firepower
and apologize for it i have also posted
a follow-up piece here oh did he
that's exactly what it meant he says
that's not what i meant that's exactly
what he said he was terrified
to gun lovers you can't even have an
opinion on assault rifles unless it's
theirs here's the proof
bro okay he says the gun debate is over
where's this article from
it's from june 15 2016. in all my years
in journalism
coming up on 30 i have never received so
much angry mail as i did after
yesterday's story
what it's like to fire an ar-15 bro it's
because you
take a turkey hunting listen if you were
hunting
pheasants or squirrels there would be a
bigger recoil than your ar-15 that's the
craziest thing i've asked all these
dudes who are like we're at the range
and i'm like what do you think and
they're like that guy's nuts
like what's the what's the weakest
possible interpretation of using a gun
hunting squirrel and he's going to have
he's going to have like game load our
bird shot and he's going to be facing
more pain he's on train too so it's like
what it's like to to
hit a baseball that's being thrown 100
miles an hour from someone that's
untrained it's going to be terrifying
they might get hit by the ball it might
break
in can we take you shooting yeah sure
let's go
let's go this weekend and i think he's
been shooting he fired he fired the 410
out of the governor
uh oh yeah together yeah you fired the
shotgun shells right yeah
so the it's it's not like a big shotgun
shell but 410 bore out of the the
revolver
it's it's it's you know it's it's pretty
big i'd say it's way uh
way i thought it was going to be way
more kickback than what it was if you're
prepared for it and you have a grip
and you're focused it's not it's very
easy doesn't this tell you how
out of touch journalists are with the
people they cover it would be so
interesting to go into one of these
newsrooms and actually if you could get
them to be honest right the daily news
the new york times
how many people own a gun and actually
know the true answer to that
how many voted for a republican maybe
there's like a janitor there
you know what i mean to see how many
people have you how many of you go to
church
how many of you uh are pro-life any of
these issues where it's like the public
is split but the institutions that cover
them
are so dominated by one side how can
anyone think even if they were
well-intentioned which i don't really
believe anymore
even if they were well intentioned i
don't see how they could cover a
population like that
the funny thing is they say this and
they acknowledge this
in terms of diversity on the skin
surface level they're saying a
nose room with no black people can't
cover america fairly which
maybe that's not true but they at least
acknowledge it in that capacity
they don't acknowledge the same thing
for actual ideas and actual perspectives
and
experiences you reminded me of that
huffington post picture where they took
a photo of of their editorial board and
one day it was all women
it was just a whole bunch of white women
and everyone's like look at how diverse
we are and i'm like wait what are you
well no no
they said they said it was it was
something like what do you notice about
our oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was
like a bunch of women it was all women
and then someone was like there's
there's it's all white people
they're like huffington posts and hire
black people and they have to like
apologize or something oh wait actually
that reminds me of something huffington
post opinion i think it was
actually publicly they released so i
used to pitch
up ads in a job that i was in and the
editor there released like
data about the percentage of minority
authors we published the percentage of
trans
authors that we published and they
promised to do better
next year they're like we will actively
ensure that we publish more black people
more trans people and it's like so
you're just openly admitting that you're
not going to publish the best articles
you're going to ask people so are you
trans by the way i need to know
so i just know whether to run this
really great op-ed but um
who do you like banging right uh can you
publish my opinion i don't know do you
like dick or do you like it
like the quality of outcome versus the
equality of opportunity
so like if they publish more people that
created
a love of all humans to work together as
opposed to
published more black people and more
women that maybe would even cause
divert like diversion you know cause
what would you call it like hate i don't
even think of the word because i don't
like it in my
lexicon yeah division so you could have
a bunch of white guys that create
a a space where everyone comes together
or you could have a black guy and a
white woman and a an
african or whatever all creating a
situation where people hate each other
it doesn't matter who they are they're
never going to publish enrique tario
when they say they want more black
writers they're not talking about
enrique or candace owens or the hodge
twins
they're talking about social justice
activists who agree with them
when they're talking about diversity
they're not talking about bringing on
people with different ideas they're
talking about people who look different
but have the exact same ideas
well and if they don't have the same
ideas then you ain't black
right yes that's joe biden for you right
so it's not it's not only just
or it's like peter thiel right the lgbt
media wrote about him that he's not
actually a gay man
he just has sex with other men because
he endorsed trump dude that's literally
an article
that was published in the advocate
uh which is supposed to be a gay rights
magazine it's it's the
the the look saying double standard
hypocrisy has become redundant at this
point
it's something special and new it's just
like
what's the what's what's a you you have
logic and you have like math
and you have formula what's the opposite
like abstract absurdity
absurdism you know it's it's articles
that are meant to make no sense on
purpose
you know it's like it's like the art you
know when you look at art it's like you
have like a beauty like we
have we have a picture over there and
it's like a beautiful like aurora
borealis and there's a lake
and that's like a real thing you know
realism
and then what's what's what's the art
called where the happiness yeah abstract
art that's what it is it's abstract
it's it's abstract politics right it's
meaningless and it's meant to be like
that's not possible a possible thing
your ideas are nonsensical
they're like perfect there are perfect
little establishment slave ninis that
are used to push the agenda and the
narrative of controlling people and
getting rid of people's freedoms
and they use it over issues and they use
it over these talking points and these
buzz words that absolutely have no
meaning just like in 1984 orwellian
doublespeak is becoming more and more of
a reality
yes yes but look what people do with
freedom in new york they bought
too large of sodas so michael bloomberg
had to put a punitive tax on it so that
people would stop buying
too large of some michael bloomberg used
his freedom to put a ban on other
people's sodas
yes yeah see you're trying to curtail
michael bloomberg's freedom
that sob had me arrested i have a long
history with him by the way uh
he's a dirty dirty politician he
promised to help out the first
responders and
the 911 first responders police officers
firefighters medics military men who
were sick and dying after 9 11 told me
hey
he's promising to to give us this
funding and support this bill if you
personally luke stop
harassing him what and confronting him
yeah yeah i don't know if you want to
get into this story but i
i every time he did a radio show every
time he did a ribbon cup
cutting every time he did a gala every
time he did a public event i was on him
like white on rice
confronting him and asking him like
you're cutting support he said that
first responders were sick because of
ptsd and not the actual
uh you know um what was it uh that that
dust that created
us asbestos yeah yeah yeah he said is oh
it's not the asbestos in the air that's
that's hurting all these
first responders and rescue workers it's
ptsd there was there
it's psychosomatic they can't breathe
did i work there no trust me there was
there was a police officer who died that
he called the not a hero james sedroga
and i was on him i was like what are you
doing cutting funding from
these incredibly important individuals
that came to new york city on 911 at
ground zero
to rescue people and now they're being
even denied basic health benefits
that they had in their contract so i was
on bloomberg because i knew many of
these guys a lot of people some of my
friends a lot of them
bloomberg never funded it a first
responder organization came to me
the john feel good foundation and they
said look luke we just got a call from
the mayor's office
he's telling us that bloomberg is
running for a re-election
we he wants you to stop questioning him
at every press conference he wants you
to stop calling into all of his radio
shows
if you leave him alone for his
re-election he will give us this bill
right i did and i went to other gala
events and i covered other uh
you know book signings other urban
cuttings where he was at i just kind of
gave him a side eye but i didn't do
anything
and i kept my word to the first
responders even though i told him that
bloomberg was going to lie
bloomberg gets reelected for a third
term one of the first thing he does is
he cuts medical benefits for
thousands of 911 first responders they
call me back this
particular organization they're like
luke he lied he screwed us over
i'm like i told you so imagine i went to
confront him and literally they had nypd
intelligence a specific branch waiting
for me
as i'm going up the escalator to one of
the gala events and then like radowski
you're coming with us i'm like what no
i'm not uh i'm going outside
they grabbed me held me down i'm like i
want to go i want to leave they're like
no you're not leaving they came back
with 15 police officers and
they said luke we told you to leave
why didn't you leave i'm like yeah i got
it here on camera that you told
that you told me i can't leave took away
the camera threw me in jail
the police officers were fans so they
they were literally like taking me out
and giving me smokes and out of the jail
cell
nypd intelligence came down made sure to
send me down to central bookings for
three days
wow during the weekend even though it
was a criminal trespassing charge that
went on for
two years found non-innocent but that
was one of the reasons
that the canadian government used to ban
me from canada for 10 years
because they said i had a criminal
arrest work so according to the fbi
what you're saying is that you confessed
to committing a crime no uh i didn't
come out
you know i was never found guilty they
dropped the charges interesting but uh
bloomberg is one of the dirtiest
nastiest politicians and it's not crazy
the democrats are fine with it because
he gives them money
when he ran for president people finally
talked about it a little but mostly
conservatives this dude has the longest
history of racism
and sexism and me too and misogyny i
mean he literally did the stop and fresh
scores like all right
you look black get up against the wall
let the police violate your civil
liberties
there's a recording of him arguing with
people about why how it's right to
racially profile
right and this guy was running on the
democratic ticket he had support yes
because he had the checks
that's really it's a surface level
commitment to all of this diversity
stuff because
ultimately they knew that they needed
him to beat trump so they decided
whatever all our standards are flexible
it's amazing that he he like look there
are arguments for
stop and frisk i don't agree i think
it's a fourth amendment violation
but there are arguments about you go
where the crime is i've heard that
before it's like well there's crime
happening there then we go there try and
stop it
he didn't even do that like there's an
actual argument for people say like well
where they supposed to go to the wealthy
areas
no bloomberg literally said but that's
what the criminals look like
oh dude i mean i was in new york city
during
stop and frisk and there was a number of
occasions where even i was grabbed up
thrown against the wall by some
disrespectful nypd officers that were
rude
that were antagonizing i got beat up by
them uh you know previously before in a
separate incident
when i was younger and they just they
just again just came up on you and they
started grabbing you all in your
personal
you know parts and i i can't even
describe what they they did
you know a number of instances but this
is the this is what they were trying to
normalize government
agents walking up to you on the street
as you're doing your business
and throwing you against your wall
insulting you and putting your their
hands down your pants
that's crazy because if that had gotten
federal traction i mean that's like
massively totalitarian yeah but that's
what these elitists that's what a lot of
these billionaires that's why a lot of
these people
call for that's what they want because
it gives them ultimate power
it gives them something that uh of
course they can't get enough of just
like money
it's it's a it's it's you know like
people
reach a certain level where they have so
much money they they only could focus on
having more money no matter how much
they have
so the same goes for power it's it's an
addictive substance just like attention
is
and it's something that needs to be
addressed against these megalomaniac
psychopaths which are in washington dc
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you